los médicos del sistema nacional de
salud realizan un paro de 48 horas y
aunque aseguran que no descuidan la
atención de emergencias y casos de kobe
19 protestan por un cambio de estas
líneas de los hospitales también exigen
mejores condiciones laborales y
salariales además del pago de un bono
cobit de posición y muy riesgo de
muertes nosotros hemos tomado estas
estas y esta protesta de 48 horas porque
el diálogo que hemos tratado de mantener
con la patronal porque estos son
patrones no son gestores no hemos
conseguido eco para solucionar los
problemas que aquejan a diario los
médicos los médicos hemos pasado de ser
una clase media vulnerable a ser
potencialmente pobres los médicos
rechazan la eficiencia del sistema
sanitario denuncian que ésta habría
impulsado casos de contagios y
fallecidos entre sus colegas pero otros
profesionales afirman que ya se están
comenzando a atender algunos reclamos
como el pago del bono kobe
así como cumplir en una primera etapa la
vida en la segunda etapa en donde va a
seguir otorgando el bono mensualmente
ahora de que sería que salud no está
pagando lo solo eso es totalmente falso
de salud cumple todos los meses con el
pago de nuestros haberes y los
beneficios que esta ley
a nadie se le dé a nadie se le ha
recortado lógico que un personal que
está haciendo el trabajo remoto y va a
querer que le paguen guardias nocturnas
y no hacerlo también es una aberración
el paro médico se produce cuando pero
tiene más de 800 ocho mil contagiados y
más de 32.000 fallecidos por el mortal
patógenos las autoridades peruanas han
alertado sobre una eventual segunda ola
de la pandemia del joven 19 dentro de
dos o tres semanas